on a des gens qui ont aucune connexion
avec ça on jamais été l'église son
combat c'est fait c'est des gens qui se
posent beaucoup de questions et qui sont
vraiment un grosse réflexion spirituelle
on peut le dire on est en train de vivre
comme ça
une réunion d'urgence un peu du milieu
chrétien puis je pense que l'église
actuelle temps de vraiment s'adapter ou
21e si par exemple en ce moment une
photo serait intégralement venait
d'acheter avec d'église plateau c'est
quand on est beaucoup de jeunes donc
c'est comme si c'est vraiment un bon
moyen de se rejoindre sur facebook ici
en un groupe facebook lancée c'est
vraiment une bonne manière de les
rejoindre mais j'aime ça quand même
beaucoup
j'ai regardé les sites de ces groupes
dans vos derniers puisqu'ils me frapper
c'est à quel point il avait saisi la
culture le bit le bide du plateau le b
du coeur de montréal foodie anti jeunes
adultes et c'est rafraîchissant parce
que on peut pas dire que c'est fréquent
chez nous nos églises plus établis
historiquement au québec de voir ça on
n'a pas commencé avec les dés de dire
voici le moyen de les attirer fait que
ça qu'on va refaire puis ça va ça va
être notre note moyens de les faire
venir nous voir les gens de notre époque
de ma génération ce quartier il s'est
terré sert à quelque chose d'authentiqué
qui cherche quelque chose d'un temps sec
je